foreign
[Music]
which I claim happened before the Big
Bang in those first millionth of a
millionth of a second the universe
expanded very very quickly that
something is very strange with our
universe at the largest scales what else
is there to be explained other than what
the universe is doing right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as George mentioned in the 1920s uh
Hubble Mr Hubble the man discovered that
the Universe was expanding it was a big
surprise in the late 1990s Hubble the
spaceship uh discovered that this
expansion of the universe was speeding
up
um this was an enormous surprise I think
it there were you know maybe a handful
of people on the planet who somehow
suspected this for one reason or another
but for most people in in cosmology in
physics this sort of blew them out of
water I know there was no reason at all
that they could think of about why this
was what was happening
um since that time the evidence for this
has really become overwhelming we have
three
um I think we'll talk about this a
little later three very direct ways of
looking at the universe and seeing that
it's true the expansion of the universe
is is speeding up
um our best theory for this uh comes
from Einstein
and the best theory is that 70 of the
energy of the universe is this
anti-gravity force field spread thinly
throughout space and making everything
repel it sounds like something from from
science fiction but we have this great
theory that Einstein gave us and it
matches the observations that we see
um I should say that it wasn't always
like this uh throughout the history of
the universe so there's something a bit
weird that happens as the universe
expands uh the galaxies in the universe
obviously get further and further apart
and so they get more dilute
but this dark energy this smeared
everywhere that doesn't get more dilute
as the universe expands it has this very
weird property that it stays exactly
constant amounts in density as the
universe expands which means that um if
you go way way back to the big bag if
you go back 14 billion years ago the
amount of dark energy in the universe
was just negligible
playing any role at all
then the universe expands and the
galaxies get further and further away
and it's only around the 10 billion year
mark that this dark energy appears to
take over so that's weird somehow
there's there's this property of the
universe that does nothing at all for 10
billion years and then takes over the
entire universe okay that's part of the
problem about why we're struggling to
understand this why are we struggling to
write down a theory a natural theory of
dark energy that you know is lethargic
for 10 billion years and then something
gets all excited and pushes the universe
um the other thing I'd I'd like to touch
upon uh in later discussions is exactly
what George was saying about the
discrepancy with with quantum theory so
there's a story which which could just
be one of the most wonderful stories in
in physics um the story is that uh if
you look um at very very small scales in
physics we have quantum mechanics uh
which is the Right theory and quantum
mechanics tells us that the vacuum of
space is a really interesting place if
you go to space and you take everything
out of it
um because of basically What's called
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
um you can't have zero energy instead
space is kind of this bubbling soup of
quantum fluctuations particles which pop
out of space and go back again and again
this is not science fiction this is
something that we can test this is
something that we've seen in
Laboratories and we can measure and we
know it's there
and a very natural question is is what
effect does this have on the universe
this bubbling Quantum soup
um and it turns out wonderfully the
effect this has is that it's dark energy
this bubbling Quantum soup makes the
entire universe want to expand and speed
up this if it could work would be
amazing I think this is our theory on a
very very smallest scales telling us
what the universe is doing on the very
biggest scales this would be one of the
great successes of science
unfortunately it doesn't work when you
do the calculation you find that the
amount of dark energy due to the
bubbling soup is a little bit too big to
explain what we see it's too big
um by about a factor of 10 to the 60.
that that's a million million I say a
million ten times right it's literally
the worst prediction in the history of
science
um and I don't know why it's wrong so
from my perspective this is why dark
energy is so exciting that we know this
Quantum stuff is there and we know
gravity is there and yet for some reason
uh the two just aren't fitting together
I think of all the hints in physics this
this is uh probably the most crucial
this is telling us that there's
something really deep and important that
we don't understand about the universe
and for me that's why this is so
exciting
thank you
foreign
it may be that the Big Bang was the
beginning as Roger has emphasized for
many years now the observed fact is that
our early universe is very very special
if you took all the different ways you
could arrange all the photons and
particles of matter in the universe the
one that we actually have for the our
observed Big Bang is extraordinarily
unlikely that's these 10 to the 10 to
the 120 something uh unlikely and so
either that was a tremendous accident we
got lucky nobody believes that or
there's a reason why that's something
that does uh seem to demand a reason why
maybe it's because it was the best it
was the simplest right
um Roger has the idea of the cycles and
the eons is another one
um so let me let me actually try to
defend this idea of inflation that has
been remarked upon a couple times
inflation seems like a cheat vis-a-vis
this particular problem because the
problem is why is universe so likely
inflation is a theory where you start in
a particular kind of state and then it
expands and cools and very naturally
becomes the universe that we see but
that place you started as Laura already
said is even more unlikely so that
doesn't seem to help
the reason why it might help is because
even though it's unlikely in this sort
of sense of all the possible ways the
universe could start it is maybe
makeable in a way that the ordinary
universe is not if you see the universe
that is all around us with uh two
trillion galaxies in the observable
universe and you wind that clock
backwards until you hit the point at
which quantum gravity is unavoidable
right the the closest thing we can come
to the beginning of the universe and you
don't believe in inflation
everything we see around us was this big
it was about one centimeter across you
might think if you're not a highly
trained professional cosmologist that's
very small yeah but if you are a highly
trained professional girl you're like
that's huge
because you're comparing it to sub
atomic scales the size of atoms and
particles so you needed a universe that
was perfectly smooth and regular across
a centimeter when all the particles that
we know about are much much smaller than
that what inflation lets you do is start
the universe much much much smaller than
that so if you have a theory for how
universes are created such as my
favorite theory of baby universes where
you start with a big empty universe and
there's a Quantum fluctuation that
bubbles off a little bubble of space
that grows into our universe
the little bubble of space that you make
is much more likely to be small than to
be big and if you want to start with a
small universe and make a big one like
ours inflation does a very good job
so I think that there can be a role for
inflation whether or not it's true I'm
not sure 10 right but nevertheless it
does serve a an obvious purpose that we
might like to take advantage of in
understanding why we started from some
place very special and got the universe
we see
thank you
um our standard model of cosmology says
that the Universe started with some
particle known as the implant on field
that was at very high energies and and
that the energy of that particle
propelled that initial small Universe
into an accelerated expansion and and in
other words the universe went through a
big bang phase and and it grew quite
large quite fast
the the observational test of that
theory known as inflation uh one of the
observational tests is the microwave
background if that story is correct what
we expect to see in the sky today all
those photons lurking around
and and all the structure distributed in
the universe since all of those effects
including structure formation originate
from that from fluctuations of that
initial inflaton field then what we
expect to see today is a very
homogeneous and and uniform distribution
of whether it's structure or the
microwave background what Planck found
is that indeed at Short scales now I'm
talking in terms of cosmological scales
so by short I mean a hundred megaparse
or 200 megaparse if the size of a Galaxy
so in in those scales indeed plan and
WMA previously found an Exquisite
agreement of what our standard model of
cosmology says and what they observe now
let me um make a caveat here whenever we
are looking at the over dense region in
the sky for example the star a Galaxy or
a collection of such objects massive
objects that will show up in a
temperature map that will show up as a
hot spot whenever you have a
concentration of mass that region is hot
if if there is emptiness
like the space between galaxies that
will show up as a cold area in the
temperature map of the sky and and
that's what plant pot was uh taking a
snapshot of this hot and cold spot the
distribution of the hot and cold spots
what they discovered is that at this
short and intermediate scales indeed
everything looks uniformly and
homogeneously distributed as as we
expected and as it should be and and
that's a major success of our standard
model of cosmology what
they discovered which makes their
findings incredibly interesting is that
this story changes drastically at the
largest possible scales if we are
looking at Scales of say the size of the
universe known as The Horizon scale or
or even shorter scales but something a
distance comparable to the size of the
universe then the homogeneity and the
uniformity of the microwave background
Sky seems to be broken
and and that was
one of the most important findings of
the sensory it was a spectacular
Discovery it had been previously of
course uh seen by uh the W map the
previous satellite experiment and even
Kobe over uh two decades ago however
first of all our statistics and
Technology were not good enough for us
to be able to to tell that what we are
looking at is not an anomaly that comes
from nature but it's a statistical fluke
or a problem with instrumentation prank
was quite Advanced and sophisticated in
in terms of those problems the
technology problems and statistical
problems they they had a lot more data
so they could carry out better analysis
and therefore they confirmed whatever
they found nobody could question or
doubt that
that effect that anomaly absorbed at the
larger scales might be due to something
else like a statistical fluke and and
that's why the the discoveries that
blank made and at those scales are
extremely important
[Music]
so here's the idea the idea is that
everything in the universe including
stuff is now a very long way away
at the beginning of the universe it
starts off very close to us
and because Universal at that point was
very small it's possible that all the
different parts of the universe behaved
in the same way and that's what could be
why the universe even on the very larger
scales today is essentially the same as
it is again
now as this expansion took place uh
imagine that you thinking of the
universe as a sort of crumpled up kids
balloon
and as you blow it up
it starts off very curved but eventually
it becomes locally at least almost flat
and that is what we see today the
universe today on the very large scales
does look foremost fun the final detail
is
Quantum fluctuations
so
we think that this energy could have
been in some sort of field maybe the
Higgs field as I said
and
those Quantum fluctuations in the Higgs
field could be the origin of
inopportunities that we see in the
universe today
so here I have again one of my uh little
animations so it went pretty quickly
ages again okay
so Quantum fluctuations of the early
Universe then by the universe
finally comes out of this inflationary
phase those fluctuations are translated
into variations in the density of stuff
in universe and in particular
fluctuations in the cosmic microwave
background
so that's the theory just to remind you
this energy here would have been
Infamous dark energy that we keep on
talking about
so this Theory works very well for
describing the origin of all the
structures in the universe
[Music]
so now I am running over time
so anyway this is the way it works so
here I have my Quantum fluctuation of a
universe
then at the end of inflation this
translates into fluctuations in the
density stuff in the universe
and in particular if I drop some dark
matter into the universe then gravity
causes that dark matter
cluster and that forms
clusters of galaxies galaxies stars
planets
and Donald Trump
[Music]
I mean physicists tell you how
accurately we can measure how the
expansion of the universe is increasing
well I have two problems with that
firstly
the galaxies that we see at the very
edge of the universe
um we're looking so far back in time
this is back before the era where Dark
Energy kicked in and I don't understand
how this means that they can be
affecting it and secondly
what do we need to know we need to know
their uh their velocities and their
distances
distances we measure using redshift we
assume that the Hubble constant is
really a constant and that it works
exactly the same for distant galaxies is
for things nearby distance is far more
problematic I can measure the distance
to the nearest stars or astronomers can
by using The Parallax of the Earth orbit
that's simple geometry we can do that
accurately to go beyond that
requires a lot of theoretical input that
certain kinds of stars always behave in
the same way and we can use them as
standard candles to go on and then that
certain kinds of galaxies behave in the
same way and we can use them as standard
candles yet everything I read in
astronomy says stars are far more
variable and galaxies are far more
variable than we had any right to expect
there must be huge error bars with these
estimates so when you tell me that we
can measure accurately the increase in
expansion of the universities large
scales I just simply do not believe it
foreign
[Music]
there's the thing called inflation now
if you look at any modern cosmology book
whether it's popular or whether it's
technical they talk about within the
first 10 to the minus 32 seconds that
means 1 over the fraction of a second
that is which is something 32 digits
long ridiculously tiny fraction of a
second the universe was supposed to have
inflated now to get you some picture of
what inflation looks like I'm putting a
powerful magnifying glass here to have a
good look and what do we see I should
point out that we don't see that that's
the handle of the magnifying glass
but uh what you see is something very
similar
let's back up to what you see in the
future so it's it's sort of a model of
what's happening there but tucks in at
the beginning
now you see
uh the reason I was not uh keen on
mentioning it here is two reasons one is
of course it might be there tucked in
and that's why we need a magnifying
glass the other reason is I don't really
believe it so this is putting me in a
bad minority but I'm already in a
minority so that doesn't matter too much
so I'm trying to say I don't believe in
this but there are good reasons to
believe in let me say what's a bad
reason is first one of the reasons
people put forward is that you want to
explain the Curious fact that the
universe is really very very uniform and
this was one of the explanations that
somehow if it was very irregular then
this inflationary phase was stretch it
all out flat
now I never believed that argument and
the sort of reason is the following
imagine that the Universe was collapsing
so time is now still going up but then
there will all be sort of wrinkles
there'll be black holes and this picture
now is not I want to use another picture
but I couldn't find it so don't you have
to imagine it a very very complicated
thing up there which doesn't look like
that in that clean little point but a
great mess up there that's the sort of
thing you get when black holes you see
this full black Souls will form and
they'll congeal and make a huge mess and
it would look horrible not like that
nice point so
why wasn't it like that the other way
around you see the equations of Einstein
work just as well in time one way or as
the other way so why was it not that
huge mess at the beginning and inflation
doesn't solve that equation that doesn't
solve that problem
but I want to talk about that because
this is a key point of the argument
and for the moment I'm not going to say
why I'm just going to say what in a
certain sense and to do that it's useful
to go back to the Escher picture which I
just showed you and we now this is a
spatial picture not time in it so it's
just space but these angels and devils
inhabit this infinite universe so
although it looks to us as they're
getting smaller and smaller to the edge
you have to imagine well you can choose
the angel or the devil whichever you
prefer that you are the same size no
matter close to the edge you are so
these fellas or fellow asses no matter
where you are you will see
um it looks just like the beginning and
the transformation involved here is
what's called conformal that is you
squash down in all directions by the
same amount so you're not just squashing
this way but you're squashing that by by
the same amount and it's a very nice
kind of geometry angles like the angle
on the wing of this devil will be the
same no matter how close to the edge you
are the eyes will be the same shape know
how close to the edge they are they're
just a different size so it's a it's a
kind of geometry very beautiful kind of
geometry where you're not interested in
distances but you're interested in in
shape small shapes or if you like angles
and this this is a very crucial part to
the argument that I want to give here so
these angels and Devils for their from
their point of view the universe is
completely infinite we look at it from a
different perspective we allow ourselves
to squash the infinity down in this
conformal way and you can imagine
stepping from here out to there they
can't do it but you could sort of
Imagine something might do that so let's
come to that
um
okay now I've now applied this to the
universe this was the picture drawn
smaller now of the history of the
universe
keeps on going out to Infinity but that
Infinity like in the angels and Devil's
picture is squashed down to this
boundary here so that represents the
Infinity of this universe
and that's quite accepted thing you can
do
the universe as far as we understand it
in the very remote future will smooth
itself out in a way which allows us to
they're very general theorem is a
theorem due to a German Helmet Friedrich
who established under very general
circumstances this conformal squashing
down can be done so there's no argument
there
what I'm doing here on the beginning is
the opposite thing I'm stretching out
the Big Bang to make it look like a nice
smooth surface now that is not something
which generally happens it only happens
when the universe starts out very very
regular and smooth in the way we seem to
see it
and there's a thing I used to call the
vile curvature hypothesis not being
bothered to explain what that means
because it's a bit Technical and my
former students and colleague Paul Todd
who had another way of saying it what is
it it says that the beginning of the
universe is conformally nice and smooth
so you can do this
that's a hypothesis if you adopt that
hypothesis then you do get this universe
which is sort of smooth in the way we
see and it's in very important for this
thing called the second law of
Thermodynamics the second law
thermodynamics says that this thing
called entropy which increases as you go
as time increases and uh
thing is that we see in the universe
observationally but it looks as though
the entropy is very very high at the
beginning when it should be very low
because it has to start low how is it
low it's low in gravity which means that
the Universe of noise I don't really
want to go into that argument I
shouldn't even started it because it
because it's key to the description but
it'll distract me too much for what I
want to say I'll just say there's good
reason for saying that this can be
stretched out it's very nice it solves a
lot of problems if that is the way the
universe for some reason stretches out
like that what's the reason well here's
what I'm saying the reason is is because
this
our universe as we think of it starting
from the Big Bang ending up with this
eternal exponential expansion going on
and on and on getting you more and more
borings as time goes on
and the argument is that that our
universe as we said as we thought is not
the whole story
that this future remember the Asher
picture can be stretched squashed down
and now it becomes the Big Bang of the
next eon
and so this is what I call consort
conformal cyclic cosmology that we are
here there was one of these eons I'm
calling them an eon I looked up in the
dictionary to make sure an eon aeon was
not an actual length of time it seems to
be around it's a long time but not a
definite length of time which is fine by
me so I've used that term here a cosmic
Eon is that but I'm claiming there was a
cosmic Eon preceding us one later than
us one perceiving before and so on and
they just continue indefinitely
foreign
[Music]